تطور النامطار للمعارك في اوكرانيا
فقواته فاجنر تطوق مدينه باخمود شمال
على بلدات مجاوره بغيه تشديد الخناق على
الجيش الاوكراني والقوات الروسيه سيطرت
على مساحات واسعه من مدينه ماركا شمال غرب
دانيت وباتت المدينه مدمرتان بالكامل
وشوارعها خاويه من السكان
الهدف من السيطره على اواخر مدينه ماهر
السيطره عليها الوصول الى اطراف مدينه
افديكا والهدف من هذا ايضا التقدم هو
الوصول الى المناطق الشماليه حيث المعارك
الاكثر سخونه حول مدينه
هنا يقاتل الجنود منذ الصباح حتى ساعه
متاخره
شديد جدا وعنيف خلفنا هنا في هذه المنطقه
بالفعل نحن على الخط الاول للمواجهه في
مدينه مارينكا المتاخمه لمدينه امل
ثم تنخفض ليلاواتير الاشتباكات في ساعات
المساء ياخذ المقاتلون قسطا من الراحه
ويحرس الخنادقه اخرون تصل الامدادات
العسكريه قبل صباح اليوم التالي وسط هدوء
الطرفين ليتبدل الفريق باكمله وتبدا
المعارك ثانيه مع شروق الشمس يوم جديد
المواقع حيث القصف المتبادل ما بين الجنود
الروس والجنود الاوكرانيين في هذه الخطوط
الاماميه
لقناتي العربيه والحدث رائد الاخضر ماهركا